welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this episode we're
breaking down the
Creator the new Sci-Fi epics easily one
of my favorite films of the year and
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing what happens in it our
thoughts on it and also that ending
heavy spoilers ahead and this is
definitely one of those films I
recommend that you go and support in a
cinema if you're one of those people who
says Hollywood doesn't do anything
original anymore then please stop the
video and go and check it out I think
it's that good but if you still here and
you want to know the spoilers or you've
seen it thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the
Creator what's
[Music]
Heaven it's a peaceful place in the
sky hey are you going to
heaven no you got to be a good person to
go to
heaven then we're the
same we can't go to heaven cuz you're
not
good and I'm not a person now the movie
opens with a block of texts that
discusses the word Nar this is an
important name throughout the film and
it Loosely translates to mean the
creator has other meanings like
manufacturer or architect but boiled
down to its usage here it of course fits
in with the movie's title Nan m is said
to be a man who understands the
incredibly Advanced AI technology and
he's helped to develop the ones that we
meet throughout the film in the opening
we get a brief history of what happened
with the tech and learn that Humanity
integrated AI into every aspect of our
life whether it was the jobs that we
didn't want to do like hitting the
Thumbs Up Button ride control or just
acting as a companion our alliance on AI
became almost like a characteristic of
the the species some of these were
called simulants and these took on the
faces of living people giving comfort
and a friendly face to those in need now
as we get into the movie we discover
that Humanity actually developed a way
to copy someone's brain and then upload
this into a simulant which we'll talk
about more later on either way it seemed
like it was a good time until one day AI
launched a nuk from an orbital weapons
platform which was called Nomad
completely destroying Central LA this
plunged the West into a war against AI
in which they've attempted to wipe out
all forms of it throughout the world
however they us have harbored them and
given Sanctuary to the machines in a
domain now known as New Asia now we pick
up in the air 2065 with our protagonist
Joshua and his wife Maya Joshua is a
double amputee but he ended up going to
Maya who fixed him up and helped him out
with his limbs the pair fell in love
Maya got pregnant and then now living
out on an island with the rest of her AI
family things go right though during a
botched operation with noad and we learn
that Josh is actually an undercover
agent ma discovers his to and as she
flees she's nuked from orbit by Nomad
and Josh returns to the US it turns out
that he'd been tasked with getting close
to Maya and this was due to her father
being know Mor now the government
thought that if they took them out they
could then end the war and finally stop
AI from developing as fast as it did as
we learned throughout the film though
Maya ended up taking on this role and in
secret she's created the most advanced
AI ever scanning her own embryo she
built a child base on her and Josh's
baby which also comes with the ability
to change and grow known as alfro this
is a reference to the Alpha and Omega
aka the beginning and the end now Alpha
o or rather Alfie for short she can
interact with all electronic items and
once she grows powerful enough she'll be
able to turn the tide and destroy the
satellite Nomad we see Josh has been
living a solitary life with him
regularly being interrogated about what
he actually knows he's constantly
downplayed what went on with Maya and we
just discover his backstory through the
events of the film now though he's taken
a step back from army life he's pulled
back into it upon being shown footage
that my is still alive tasked with
destroying the facility that houses
Alpha o he realizes there's something
different about her and over the film
The peir start to bond in hindsight we
know this is the embodiment of his
daughter and though he's tasked with
killing her he finds it difficult to do
he catches Alfie drawing a picture of a
tattoo Maya had and he basically wants
her to lead him to his wife now what's
great about the Creator is that you have
so many sides in there that constantly
try and get their hands on the pair
you've got the Americans who think Josh
is done a runner and then the AI who
hate him because his mission is to kill
her in the West's eyes Alfie seen as a
weapon and thus must be taken out which
Josh almost does at its heart though
this is a father and daughter movie
about him trying to get back to his wife
and correct the wrongs of the past
unaware this will create a family but
things unfortunately don't end up
turning out that way upon reaching Maya
we see she's in a K State and has been
on life support since that first strike
simulants are unable to harm NE and thus
they've been waiting for someone like
Josh to turn off the machines copying
her brain he then shuts them down and
all this happens as the US arrive I
think what the film does excellently is
that it holds aera up to man and shows
all the evil things that we are capable
of we actually learned that the attack
on La was down to a coding error and
that the AI actually had nothing to do
with it now you will end up feeling for
these machines as you see them scream in
agony and act in a way that makes them
truly human even some of the people we
come across plead out for Josh not to
kill their Bots but he constantly says
that they're not real now at the heart
of the Creator is him learning that they
are and it's a theme that's at the heart
of a lot of sci-fi films Blade Runner
asked the question whether if a human
was replicated perfectly if that would
make them human or they'd still be a
machine if everything from Bones to
tissu to personality was the same but
the difference was they had a serial
number somewhere would that make them
something that wasn't considered real
it's up for you to decide that yourself
but I love how there's this ambiguity
and Shades of Gray in the film The
Creative team do a great job of making a
go back and forth on that and
questioning whether we ourselves would
sympathize with the AI it's a movie that
will also have you asking are we the
baddies cuz humans kill both man and
machine without prejudice have come the
Final Act even the most Harden day I
hating character they come to realize
that it's not all black and white in the
movie Josh's boss is Colonel Howell and
she's played brilliantly by Alice and
jany we discovered that she had two sons
who died due to the machines with one
being tortured for hours and hours and
hours H makes it to Nada and asks for
Alfie to be handed over but in this
moment she's shot up by kenw and ob's
Haron he attaches an explosive directly
to her back which detonates after a
certain time period over in this moment
Alfie de abl say it and I think you can
see that she truly understands
unfortunately this doesn't last long as
Alfie and joshia forced to flee which
reactivates the explosive and then kills
her and her men during this time though
Josh grabs a copy of Maya's brain which
becomes important in his final few
moments throughout the film he's
constantly said he'd give up everything
to have another moment with her and not
only has he freed her in death but he's
also retained a copy Maya was seen as
someone that was stuck in limbo and
unable to go to heaven and this was due
to her vegetative state now Heaven is
another IDE throughout the film where
the characters constantly questioning
whether they'll get to go now du to the
lack of intelligence on the mission
Josh's true goals aren't known and he's
lorded as a hero they just see him as
someone who's brought in the weapon and
they're now free to launch attacks
across New Asia now as he's brought in
one of the soldiers says they're not
real and he clearly sees them
self-reflected in this guy however as
he's come to learn they are more than
machines and he does start to realize
exactly how deep they go now it said
that Alfie won't let them shut her down
though and thus Josh is sent in to be
the one to deal the killing blow however
all he does is put her on standby and as
her body's taken across La they make
their final move boarding a flight they
hijack it and go directly to Nomad where
Alfie sent of the center to shut the
thing down on the outside Josh scales
the satellite and he places an explosive
onto one of the nukes now inside Alfie
comes across a model based on her mother
which she activates by putting the brain
scan into unfortunately for her this
doesn't start up immediately unless she
heads out to Joshua the PE both head for
an escape pod Josh is caught and he has
to sacrifice himself in order for her to
make it back to Earth he talks about how
he never thought that he'd get to heaven
but him helping Alfie is what guaranteed
he will in some ways we symbolically see
this play out as Josh walks through the
station and gets into the garden here he
sees Maya and the pair run towards each
other with which obviously Echoes images
of the afterlife most of us when we
imagine something like heaven it's us
being reunited with our loved ones that
have passed away the garden surrounding
and just a pair running to each other is
of course symbolic of that on a number
of different levels no man itself is the
quote unquote Heavens with it hanging
above Earth and looking down on all it's
very much like a God's eye un able to be
touched with it being a benevolent
entity that RS down on all the idea of
God is a more abstract thing as well as
humans themselves have now learned to
create life thus the idea of God
something we've managed to match and I
love this subtext that's ler out the
film but technically Maya isn't real she
is just a machine but even as an
audience you don't feel that seeing the
scene this is very much Josh reunited
with his wife and getting to go to the
heaven that he always wanted to be in it
just goes to show how much we become
attached to the machines too and we can
totally see them as being real people
also I know there's some back and forth
over whether joshh should have died but
due to how he acted I think the guy kind
of needed to let's not beat around the
bush yet he wasn't a good dude all the
time and this movie is very much about
his Redemption Arc now a sacrifice isn't
in vain as we see on Earth that Nomad
comes crashing down both humanity and AI
celebrate side by side with us getting
several shots of machines and people
hugging it out think throughout the film
it's shown AI isn't as bad as it's made
out to be and that it doesn't have the
desire to kill that human someone
possess we of course evolved during a
time where it was a necessity to survive
whereas the AI were created when there
wasn't as much need for it thus they
don't have our violent past in history
and would rather coexist alongside us
than wiping each other out and that's
something that a lot of humans share
with them clearly seeing the souls
inside of the machine even a soldier
that Josh worked with at the start of
the movie he ends up falling in love
with a simulant woman and it does go to
show how we can attach ourselves to them
so yeah there's there's definitely these
themes which the Creator itself hammers
home perfectly in the end we close out
with Alfie looking out on a world where
the machines can be free alongside the
humans they'll no longer be targeted
from the sky and stamped up by the west
and the war will finally end with us all
coexisting Heron at one point talks
about what would happen if the machines
W and he just says that that it would be
nothing Humanity will be given the same
rights that machines have and I I feel a
bit bad for slagging off the secret
Invasion title sequence now no no you
know you know what I'm saying and
actually really like the idea of
coexistence rather than extermination
that's something that AI films are often
painting out with the Terminator and
Matrix being the key contenders in the
letters though even the humans and
machines have to learn to live together
and I think that's the main message that
the movie is driving home we very much
open Pandora's Box and creating
technology that's smarter faster and in
every way starting to surpass us I have
to admit it's worrying when even the
creative things we do are being copied
by machines and put out at a faster rate
than we could ever do I think the
creator has a more optimistic message
though instead of giving us the nihilism
that we've had movies about someone who
was taught to hunt machines learning to
love them and see them as human that's a
true message that I take from the film
with it saying artificial life is still
life now as of my thoughts on the movie
I thought it was an incredible
achievement with it easy being one of my
favorite films of the year I think at
some points the p in might have been a
bit too fast and I would have liked to
remained in in certain moments longer
for example there's a couple of cuts
where we see Josh coming across copies
of Maya but we don't really see the
emotional impact that it has this has
been the man's mission in the movie but
it just goes by so quickly and doesn't
give us a gut punch just little things
like that are laout the film but they're
very minor nitpicks and what's an
incredible achievement the Creator is
such a well-made and thought out film
that it was difficult for me to not feel
like I was was seeing an instant classic
unfold whether it's the chapter titles
or designer lived in World it all feels
like something that has a unique style
of its own it's incredible this was done
on an $80 million budget when we've got
$300 million movies that look like
they've got Playstation 2 graphics I
think this movie can almost be like an
expose on Hollywood that slams it for
its bad CGI and unoriginal films this is
an incredible piece and I really hope
those constantly screaming there's
nothing good anymore you got eyes go out
and see it give it all the support it
deserves and obviously I'm sure you can
tell that I I really did like it a movie
like this that that's based around The
Human Condition is of course also
relying on its key performances everyone
feels like they're really bringing the
role with Alfie's actress especially
being a standout played by metalin un of
oils this is her very first film but she
handles every emotion expertly and gives
a cracking performance John David
Washington's at his best too giving what
I I feel is his most ranged character I
thought in 10ed he was a bit subdued but
here he really gets to show off his
great acting skills the side characters
work really well too especially Chris
Finch Chris Finch bloody good rep and
all in all it's an incredible film I
think that movies like this should
definitely be supported so make sure you
go out and check out this film send that
message to Hollywood we want more
original works like this where they've
clearly put an effort to make something
special all in all I completely love the
film and that's why it's getting a 9 out
of 10 now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on it you know am I am I
saying it's too good am I not giving it
that perfect 10 that it deserves comment
below yeah and just let me
[Music]
know see
bills
if you enjoyed the video then please hit
the thumbs up button and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button you'll get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out now if you
want to get some heavy spoilers merch
we've also got our t-shirt line located
just below the video that will let you
pick up all kinds of tops like our
Theory time one house the dragon stuff
Marvel Tas and more you drop new designs
on there all the time too so definitely
keep an eye out for them and yet huge
thank you you bought one now if you want
something else to watch we've got a
breakdown of the latest episode of
Ahsoka which will be linked on screen
right now talk about all the Easter eggs
in it lots of things to go over so yeah
definitely head over there right after
this by the way huge thank you for sing
through the video I've been Paul and
I'll see you next time you take care
peace